I don't think it's going to surprise too
many people who are in our audience to
hear what I'm about to tell you but it
has now been revealed that many of the
lawyers representing Donald Trump in his
Senate impeachment trial are Republican
donors two Republican senators currently
in the Senate who will be the ones
voting to either convict or acquit
Donald Trump now this changes nothing
about the reality of the foregone
conclusion that is Donald Trump's
acquittal in the Senate but the
incredible contrast of this is that
there were some Republicans saying you
know Bernie and Warren should recuse
themselves from the entire Senate trial
they shouldn't be allowed to vote on
Trump's impeachment conviction or
acquittal because Bernie and Warren and
Clovis are are running for the
Democratic nomination they could
potentially be facing Donald Trump in
the general and it's a conflict of
interest now they never actually make
explicit what kind of a conflict of
interest it is I guess it's they might
vote to convict so they don't have to
face Trump in the general or something
like that but in any case Democrats
don't have the votes to convict so it's
relatively moot but now we find out wait
a second the Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell the top Republican in
the Senate who is involved in running
the trial who's involved in setting the
rules for the trial who's involved in
deciding if and when there will be a
debate about calling witnesses Mitch
McConnell received campaign donations
from two of Donald Trump's lawyers
Kenneth Starr one of Donald Trump's
lawyers donated the maximum in the past
two in in the last year to Mitch
McConnell and has given more money to
Mitch McConnell in the past
Robert Rea another Trump lawyer gave
fifty six hundred dollars to Mitch
McConnell's Senate re-election committee
we are also now learning that Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham who will be
voting on whether to convict Trump was
in the loop himself about the effort to
find dirt on the Biden's in Ukraine this
is according to lev par ness a now
indicted henchmen of trumps personal
lawyer Rudy Giuliani it's like a game of
Clue so let me say that again one of the
senators who will get to vote convict or
acquit for Donald Trump was allegedly in
the
the entire time about the effort to find
dirt about the Biden's in Ukraine to
help Trump get elected in 2020 he will
be voting okay we have to hear from left
Parnas I don't know if we will we have
to hear from john bolton i don't know if
we will but can there even be a fair
trial here we started with a trial that
had as a foregone conclusion its outcome
the acquittal of donald trump likely by
all 53 republican senators in the senate
remember you need 67 to convict a
president on impeachment in the senate
we had those same Republicans start to
argue we don't even need witnesses that
fight will happen in the Senate today
maybe it's already happening when
senators actually debate and vote on
witnesses but half or nearly half of the
Senate thinks it's perfectly fine to
have a trial without calling material
witnesses like john bolton and now we
find out that at least some of the
senators who will be voting were either
involved tangentially in the actions
that led to impeachment seeking dirt in
ukraine or have received campaign cash
from the lawyers representing donald
trump do you think that when trump's
team wants for example no debate about
witnesses until after each side has
presented and they've donated to Mitch
McConnell and Mitch McConnell says he's
coordinating everything with the White
House and then McConnell comes out and
says hey you know what I agree let's not
talk about witnesses until the trial is
almost over are we supposed to believe
that everything is on the up-and-up
it is mind-bending corruption there are
millions of Americans just not paying
attention because they have busy lives I
understand it they're earning a living
and there is mind-bending corruption
going on there are millions of Americans
who know what's going on and don't care
because they either love anything that
will vindicate Donald Trump as they see
it even a false vindication and then of
course there are simply ignorant people
who are unable to really put the facts
together and build a picture of what is
going on they're in on it one way or the
other
Lindsey Graham doesn't want witnesses
because he was in on it McConnell
doesn't want witnesses because Trump's
lawyers donated to him and they don't
want it and he's the guy who says I am
going to be in complete coordination
with the White House on the impeachment
trial it's a crude analysis but we're
often finding that the simplest
explanation
explanation for the facts is often a
pretty good one and it's a very ugly
ugly reality let me know what you think
about these latest revelations we are
just two days from the david pakman
Sunday birthday membership special it's
my birthday on Sunday we are going to do
an email blast to everybody who signs up
for our mailing list you do that you do
that on my website david pakman.com it's
really easy just type in your email
address you don't need to email me
saying please put me on the mailing list
you can sign up for the mailing list on
the website on sunday you will get an
email with very specific instructions as
to how to take advantage of this crazy
whacked-out delusional discount my mom
called me and said I caught wind of this
discount are you ok are you feeling okay
because the discount seems out of
control get on the mailing list you'll
be notified Sunday one of our sponsors
is privacy calm they're giving you $5.00
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy dot-com slash
Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them any time you want so
when you do this it means you're not
going to be charged when you don't want
to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number right after using it
which for instance I love using free
trials because I know I won't be charged
when the trial is over if I use a
virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a $10 a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
$25 a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm slash
Pakman